MINING.
MINING HERE ROF WILKE PRESIDENT
WILL HERE ADKINS HERE ADKINS
HERE THANK YOU AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT -- MISTER ROTH IS ON HIS
WAY HE'S GOT A ANOTHER COMMITTEE
MEETING SO -- HE WILL BEHERE --
AND I KNOW THAT MISS BATES IS --
ALSO IN A SIMILAR SITUATION WE
HAVE VERY BUSY COMMITTEES.
HAPPENING -- TODAY -- I WILL
BEFORE WE START WITH ITEM NUMBER --
ONE A AND B. I WILL -- IT WILL
BE AN OPEN -- A CONSENT AGENDA --
APPROVED ON CALL BECAUSE WE WILL
HAVE MEMBERS SO.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION.
ON IT MY ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNORS APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR ITEM THREE
BILL REFERRAL ITEM.
FOR APPOINTMENTS ITEM FIVE A
RULE WAIVER REQUEST ITEMS SIX
THROUGH EIGHT WITCHER FLORIDA
KNOWLEDGE MINT UNDERSTANDING
THAT -- WHEN WE DO GET THE FINAL
VOTE MISS BATES IS GOING TO WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT ON ITEM NUMBER?
FIVE SO I'M HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN --
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS BATES
MINING.
MINING I ROTH WILL LOOK.
WILL TIE ATKINS I CAN SIGN AND
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MEMBERS WHEN THEY ARRIVED BUT WE
WILL GO AHEAD.
AND TURN IT OVER TO OUR FIRST
APPOINTMENT FOR CONSIDERATION --
DAVIDHOTCH CHILD WHO IS THE
STATE ENERGY RESOURCES
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION CHAIR.
AND SAY WELCOME AND I WILL
INVITE YOU TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS INTRODUCE ANYONE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO WITH YOU AND THEN
WE'LL GET INTO -- COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM AND SENATORS --
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU THIS AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAVID OKAY CHILDREN
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ENERGY COMMISSION WITH YOUR
PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY
INTRODUCE MY FAMILY.
MY A AMAZING WIFE CYNTHIA LEE IS
A DOCTOR -- ORIGINALLY FROM
TEXAS FORTUNATELY SHE WILL BE
ROOTING FOR THE WARRIORS WHEN
THEY FACE THE ROCKETS --
PLAYOFFS.
ARE YOUNGEST DAUGHTERS SONYA IS
IN FIFTH GRADE AT THE U. MING
SCHOOL IN OAKLAND SHE DOES
GYMNASTICS.
AND OUR OLDER DAUGHTER ROSA IS
IN EIGHTH GRADE SHE SINGS OPERA
AND DOES TAKE ONE DON'T.
AND ALSO JOINED BY MY WIFE'S
PARENTS TO HIM IN A FAMILY --
AND MY FATHER ADAM HOPE CHILLED --
DIFFICULT TO GET MY DAD OUT OF
THE HOUSE SO THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY
WELCOME TO TO EVERYONE WELCOME.
SO FOR SOME SAY IT'S AN HONOR TO
DO THIS WORK -- I FEEL THE
STAKES ARE ENORMOUSLY HIGH FOR
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE AND MICHAEL AS
CHAIR OF THE COMMISSION ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES IS TO MAKE
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
A FORCE FOR GOOD.
IN HELPING OUR STATE.
SUCCESSFULLY.
MEET THE CHALLENGES OF THE DAY
AND BUILD THIS CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE TOGETHER.
AND EXTEND THE BENEFITS OF THIS
TRANSITION TO A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE TO EVERY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I'M
PRIVILEGED TO WORK WITH A
DEDICATED HARDWORKING STAFF AND
A DISTINGUISHED GROUP OF FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS INCLUDING OUR VICE
CHAIR THERE SCOTT COMMISSIONER
ANDREW MCALLISTER.
THE COMMISSIONER KAREN DOUGLAS
ARE FORTUNATELY THANKS TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOME LATER THIS
MONTH I'LL BE SWEARING IN OUR
NEWS COMMISSIONER.
PATRICIA MONAGHAN WHICH MONTH
MARKS A VERY IMPORTANT MILESTONE
BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IN THE FORTY FOUR YEAR HISTORY
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION WE WILL HAVE A
MAJORITY OF WOMEN COMMISSIONERS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS WE
BUILD A CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE WE
WANT TO BUILD AN ENERGY
COMMISSION AND ENERGY INDUSTRY
THAT LOOKS LIKE CALIFORNIA.
ARE THE OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE AS I
IMPORTANT INCUBATOR ROLLED A
MODERN WINDOWS TREE THE MODERN
STEEL INDUSTRY THE MODERN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE HISTORY WE'RE
ALL BORN IN CALIFORNIA SPREAD
AROUND THE WORLD.
THE FIRST ENERGY EFFICIENCY
CODES AND STANDARDS.
ARE BORN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SPREAD AROUND THE WORLD AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE DOING A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE LOOKING WE HAD
SIXTY SIX INTERNATIONAL
DELEGATIONS BUT THAT LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE A GREAT STORY TO TELL IN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS WE'VE GIVEN
OUT ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS. TO DO ENERGY EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES THROUGH PROP THIRTY
NINE IN SCHOOLS IN EVERY COUNTY
IN THE STATE THOSE SCHOOLS ARE
NOW SAVING OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
ON THEIR ENERGY BILLS WHICH IS
MONEY THAT GOES BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM TO HIRE TEACHERS.
AND EXPENDED BY TEXT BOOKS --
WE'RE DOING THINGS LIKE MICRO
GRIDS ON FIRE DEPARTMENTS I
DEDICATED ALONG WITH MAYOR MADE
FROM FREMONT WHO'S HERE WITH US
AS WELL -- THE SOLE AMERICA GET
ON THE FREMONT FIRE DEPARTMENT
LAST WEEK WE DID ONE FOR THE
RANCHERIA TRIBE A BULLET
RANCHERIA UP IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY --
TO PROVIDE RESILIENCE AND IS AS
AN EXAMPLE -- NOT LONG AFTER WE
BUILT THAT BIKER GRID.
A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PROJECT
THERE WAS A FIRE THE GREAT WHEN
OUT IN THEIR FIRST AID CENTER
WAS ABLE TO STAY OPEN BECAUSE OF
THAT -- AND YOU LOOK AHEAD AND
WHAT WHAT ELSE WE'RE DOING THE
PLANT THE SEEDS OF THE ENERGY
FUTURE A LOT OF IT DOESN'T GET
ATTENTION BUT IT MATTERS A LOT
THINGS LIKE.
TELEVISION STANDARDS WE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE ADOPTED THE
STANDARDS CUT THE ENERGY USE OF
TV'S AND HALF.
THE SELLING OUR MARKET YOU HAVE
TO COMPLY WITH THE STANDARDS
THAT SEE IF CALIFORNIANS A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR REDUCES
POLLUTION.
REDUCES REPAIR COSTS -- GOING
FORWARD I WANT TO DO A BETTER
JOB OF TELLING THE SUCCESS
STORIES HELPING OTHER STATES AND
OTHER NATIONS -- FOLLOW SUIT --
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE ARE STEEP.
MANDELA OF BUT I THINK THE
OPPORTUNITY.
IS INSTRUMENT AS WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA
START WITH IT DO YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE MR ROTH YOU HAVE TO GO TO
A COMMITTEE.
THE WAY THEY ARE.
OKAY HUMM I WILL ET HER BUT I
START WITH YOU SENATOR ROTH --
WE ALWAYS WANT TO BE EFFICIENT
AND HELP OUR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
DOING MULTIPLE THINGS AT A TIME
SO I'LL START WITH YOU.
VENTURE RESOLUTION SIR I LOOK
FORWARD -- TO MOVING YOUR
CONFIRMATION AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME.
HOW DIFFICULT IS IT GOING TO BE
FOR US TO RETAIN OUR -- STATES
CLEAN ENERGY AND AND GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT THOSE HERE
WE'VE TAKEN A BUNCH OF VOTES
OVER THE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
HERE AND I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHAT YOUR THOUGHT IS ON THAT AND
HOW DIFFICULT IS IT GOING TO BE
TO ATTAIN.
THOSE WHAT TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO
HOPE FOR THE FUTURE IN ORDER TO
GET THERE.
THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION SO LET'S JUST START
WITH WHERE WE ARE NOW WE'RE AT
34% RENEWABLES IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE TRIPLED RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCTION LAST TEN YEARS.
I'M SORRY WE TROUBLED RENEWABLE
ENERGY PRODUCTION LAST TEN YEARS
IN OUR STATE WE DON'T COUNT
LARGE HYDRO IS A RENEWABLE THE
MANY OTHER COMMITTEES DO.
OF YOU HAVE LARGE HYDRO WORD
ABOUT 45% TODAY IF YOU ADD THE
ABLOW WE'RE ABOUT 55%.
CARBON FREE TODAY SO MY VIEW IS
THAT GETTING 2100% IS.
A CHALLENGE BUT IT'S ABSOLUTELY
A SOLVABLE CHALLENGE I THINK
GETTING 280% IS RELATIVELY EASY.
GETTING 9% IT'S HARD GETTING
2100% IS REALLY HARD BUT THERE'S
NOTHING ABOUT THAT THAT'S
OUTSIDE THE REALM OF A SOLVABLE
PROBLEM.
AND THE TECHNOLOGIES WERE
DEVELOPING NOW TO HELP
MANIPULATE DEMAND WE HAVE WE'VE
DONE THINGS THAT WE FUNDED.
THIRTY SEVEN ENERGY STORAGE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS --
THERE'S ENORMOUS POTENTIAL SO A
LOT OF OTHER STATES ARE WATCHING
WHAT WE DO AND IN FACT ON THE
100% -- WE NOW HAVE THAT IN LAW
IN NEW MEXICO AND DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA IN A WHITE EIGHT OTHER
STATES HAVE INTRODUCED THAT
LEGISLATION -- WHERE TWENTY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE'S
ANOTHER FOUR HAVE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO STUDY IT -- SO
WE'RE BEING WATCHED CLOSELY I AM
VERY OPTIMISTIC BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN ENORMOUS COST REDUCTION
WHEN I GOT INTO THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY. TWENTY YEARS AGO -- IT
WAS FIFTY CENTS A KILOWATT HOUR
WE ARE FIRST BID IN CALIFORNIA
LAST SUMMER -- UNDER TWO CENTS A
pWITH COST REDUCTION SO I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN MEET THE TEST.
ARE THE IS IS STORAGE THE
LIMITING FACTOR.
WELL SO IT'S A DAY TO THINK
ABOUT IT IT'S NOT LIKE US ONE
SILVER BULLET SOLUTION IT'S
REALLY SILVER BUCKSHOT STORAGE
IS ONE OF THE THINGS YOU NEED.
YOU NEED INTELLIGENT ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING PROTOCOLS WE
WANT TO HAVE WHAT I CALL AN
EEVEE HAPPY HOUR WHERE THEY'RE
PLUGGED IN TO THE GRID WHEN WE
HAVE SURPLUS RENEWABLE ENERGY
GENERATION.
THERE'S DEMAND RESPONSE TO BE
ABLE TO THERE'S THINGS LIKE PRE
COOLING BUILDINGS ANOTHER LOAD
THAT'S FLEXIBLE -- YOU LOOK AT
THE NEXT WAVE OF TRANSPORTATION
IT'S COMING ELECTRIC SCHOOL
BUSES ARE AN ENORMOUS ASSET
BECAUSE THEY'RE ACTUALLY PLUGGED
IN.
A TO THE GRID -- DURING THE
MIDDLE OF THE DAY WHEN WE HAVE
SURPLUS RENEWABLES ALL THESE
THINGS.
TAKEN TOGETHER ARE HOW WE HOW
WAS AND ALSO AS A DIVERSITY OF
RENEWABLE ENERGIES ENERGY SOURCE
OF WE DON'T WANT ALL SOLAR WE
WANT -- GEOTHERMAL AND BIOMASS
AND OFFSHORE WIND AND ALL THE
REST.
THE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS.
GOING TO BE -- HEAVILY FOCUSED
ON HEAVY DUTY TRUCK --
TECHNOLOGIES HOW HOW DOES THE
ENERGY COMMISSION INTERFACE WITH
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD ON THAT
PARTICULAR SUBJECT IF AT ALL.
SO WE HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEM WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
THEM WE GIVE AWAY ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
TO SUPPORT CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
AND PARTNER WITH THEM -- WE HAVE
FUNDED SOME HEAVY DUTY.
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES AND ACTUALLY THE
NEW COMMISSIONER WHO'S COMING IN
COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN WILL BE
THE LEAD FOR THAT SHE'S GOT
TWENTY YEARS OF BACKGROUND -- IN
TRANSPORTATION OUR CURRENT VICE
CHAIR JIMMY SCOTT'S TO THE
TREMENDOUS JOB LEADING THAT
EFFORT BUT IT'S AN ISSUE BY
ISSUE -- COORDINATION WITH THEM.
THANK YOU SIR CONGRATULATIONS
AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
CONSIDER.
YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIRMAN
YOU WANT TO GO NEXT.
SURE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SO I KNOW I DON'T NORMALLY ASK
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD ALREADY
DONE IN PRIVATE I WAS A LITTLE
UNDER THE WEATHER WHEN WE MET SO
SOME STUFF POPPED UP SINCE I
KNOW YOU CAN HANDLE SO IT'S NOT
A BIG DEAL.
SO I HYDROGEN CARS.
I'VE DRIVEN I HAD DRIVEN AND
THEY'RE VERY IMPRESSIVE BUT
THERE'S THERE'S NO
INFRASTRUCTURE -- YOU SEE IF YOU
TURN HYDROGEN CARS AND IF SO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO TO MAKE
THAT A REALITY.
SO THERE IS A STATE GOAL WHICH
IS TWO HUNDRED HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS.
I WILL SAY YOU KNOW THE MOMENTUM
IN THE INVESTMENT AMONG
AUTOMAKERS NOW SHIFTED.
THAT TEND TO ONE FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES VERSUS HYDROGEN CARS.
WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ELECTRIC VEHICLES IN
THE STATE AND SIX THOUSAND HI
GIN FUEL CELL PASSENGER VEHICLES.
ARE JUST TO BE TOTALLY CANDID I
THINK THE SHIP HAS SAILED IN
TERMS OF PASSENGER VEHICLES I
THINK THE THE MOMENTUM IS VERY
CLEARLY.
TOWARDS ELECTRIC I THINK THE
NIECE HYDROGEN IS BEST SUITED
FOR US REALLY AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKING -- AND AND AROUND PORTS
AND SO FORTH AND SO WE'VE BEEN
FINDING SOME SOME WORK IN THAT
AREA.
A GREAT.
SO I MEAN HISTORY APPOINTMENTS
I'M JUST CURIOUS WHAT DO YOU SEE
AS THE HIGHLIGHTS OF YOUR FIRST
TERM.
IN MAY AND WHAT ARE SOME OF YOUR
GOALS FOR THE SECOND TERM IT
MAYBE TOUCH ON BECAUSE I THINK
THE WAY WE'RE GOING TO ATTACK
CLIMATE CHANGE THROUGH
INNOVATION AND YOU SURE SOME
VERY INTERESTING THINGS WITH ME
AT THE OTHER DAY SO.
YOU COULD TOUCH ON THOSE I'D
APPRECIATE YOUR FIRST WITH THE
CHALLENGES I WOULD SAY THE P.
GINNY.
BANKRUPTCY IS A COLOSSAL
CHALLENGE AND THE PROSPECT OF
ELECTRIC RATES SICK IN
INCREASING SIGNIFICANTLY IS A
MAJOR CONCERN ELECTRIC RATES
THEMSELVES TODAY OUR CLIMATE
POLICY.
BECAUSE IT'S THE CASE TODAY
EVERYWHERE IN EVERY ELECTRIC
SERVICE TERRITORY IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S CHEAPER. TO DRIVE A MILE ON
ELECTRIC CAR THAN IT IS FROM
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE.
ELECTRIC RATES DOUBLING UP 80%
THAT'S NO LONGER THE CASE IT'S
CHEAPER EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO HEAT YOUR WATER WITH ELECTRIC
HEAT PUMP WATER HEATER THAT'S
CLEAN -- THEN IT IS A NATURAL
GAS WATER THAT'S NOT THE CASE OF
ELECTRIC RATES GO UP SO FINDING
A WAY THROUGH THIS P. GINNY.
SITUATION IN A WAYTHAT DOESN'T --
ADVERSELY IMPACT ELECTRIC RATES
IS PARAMOUNT NOT JUST TO THE
BETTER THE RATE PAYERS BUT TO
THE BENEFIT.
OF OUR CLIMATE GOALS -- WITH
RESPECT TO WHERE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION IS COME I AM.
REALLY PROUD OF THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE I MEAN I I'VE JUST
FINISHED DOING A DEEP DIVE
DIVISION REVIEW.
WITH -- ALL OF OUR DIVISIONS --
WE GAVE OUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR.
ON AND TELL ME THE LEVEL OF
PROFESSIONALISM THE MOTIVATION
TO FIRE IN THE BELLY -- AT THE
DEPUTY LEVEL IS AS STRONG AS
IT'S EVER BEEN -- AND WE'RE
GETTING THE AREA WHERE I REALLY
WANT TO PROVE ON PERSONAL WOULD
LIKE MORE RESOURCES SO.
PLEASE -- SEND HEM OUR WAY IN
TERMS OF WE WANT TO BE DOING
MORE THIS PARTICULAR AROUND
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WILL PLAY
TO YOUR QUESTION SENATOR --
SPECIALLY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
HELPING INTEGRATE RENEWABLES --
SUCCESSFULLY MORE QUICKLY AND
DRIVE INNOVATION WE HAVE TWELVE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE -- MANUFACTURES
NOW IN THE STATE AND AND MORE
WILL COME AS THE MARKET.
EXPANDS BUT THE THEORY I REALLY
WANT TO DRILL DOWN AND IS IS
ACTUALLY TELLING THE SUCCESS
STORIES BECAUSE THERE'S AN
ENORMOUS SUCCESS STORIES I MEAN.
THE STATE HAS FUNDED ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND AND THAT WE HAVE
THE LARGEST MANUFACTURING SITE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DAYS
ELECTRIC VEHICLE FACTORY TESLA.
I WORKED ACROSS THE STREET FROM
THEIR WEIGHT WHEN I WAS IN
SILICON VALLEY WHEN IT WAS THE
THE GM FACTORY AND TESSA PLACE
TWICE AS MANY PEOPLE THAT SITE --
AS WINNERS JIM SO THE POTENTIAL
TO GO BIG IS THERE -- BUT THE
YOU KNOW THE PHILOSOPHY WE HAVE
TO FOLLOW IS WHAT I CALL THE
PHILOSOPHY OF SUSTAINED ORDERLY
DEVELOPMENT WHERE YOU SET LONG
TERM STABLE POLICIES WHICH WE
NOW HAVE SP ONE HUNDREDS OF
FOUNDATIONAL POLICY -- ALONG
WITH MANY OTHERS -- AND GET AWAY
FROM THE EARLY MISTAKES THAT WE
MADE WHICH HAD TO DO WITH HAVING
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO LAST FOR
ONE YEAR AND THEN COLLAPSES AND
GETS RESTARTED YOU CAN'T.
BUILD A COMPANY YOU CAN'T PLAN
YOU CAN'T GROW WITH THAT I THINK
WE'VE LEARNED THAT LESSON AND
THAT'S THAT'S WERE TRYING TO
FOLLOW.
I APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWERS
LOOKING FOR DEVOTING ON YOUR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
VERY MUCH SENATOR BAIT.
IT IS FEAR AGAIN THIS HOUSE I AM
THEN WE HAD A VERY VERY
PRODUCTIVE -- DISCUSSION IN MY
OFFICE IN FACT I THINK I TOOK UP
MORE TIME IN ASKING YOU THE
QUESTIONS AND YOU HOW.
TO HOW DO YOU ANSWER BECAUSE
IT'S A SUCH A IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THING IS WE ARE
APPROACHING ARE THE ISSUES
REGARDING OUR CLIMATE CHANGE ONE
QUESTION ON NOW THAT'S ALL I
REALLY HAVE BECAUSE I FELT
COMFORTABLE WHEN YOU TALKED
ABOUT DIVERSIFICATION IN TERMS
OF HOW WE PRODUCE OUR ENERGY.
BUT ARE THE FOLDER ISSUE WHICH
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON I
DIDN'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK YOU HOW YOU ARE ADDRESSING
THE CONCERN.
THAT'S BEGINNING ON IN THIS
GENERATION REGARDING HOW WE
DISPOSE OF THE SOLAR PANELS ARE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THEY ARE
SPECIFIC LIFE CYCLE.
AND THERE IS A CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE NOT ADDRESSED THAT IN
PROBABLY EARLIER IS BETTER.
OUR WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT I
THINK COMES THING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ARE COMING ON WITHIN
THE TWENTY YEAR LIFESPAN OF A
SOLAR PANEL.
ANY THOUGHTS ON MATTERS THAT
WOULD THAT BE ON YOUR TO DO LIST
ISSUE -- YOU KNOW.
YEAH SWORN IN AND THEN START
YOUR OWN YOUR OWN PROGRAM YOUR
YOUR WORK PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I SHOULD NOTE -- IN
A FEW WEEKS WE'RE GONNA BE
MARKING -- THE OCCASION OF
CALIFORNIA HITTING ONE MILLION --
SOLAR ROOF TOPS -- AND BOB
RUMORS HERE WITH US AS WELL AND
THE AUDIENCE THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS
BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN THE SOLAR
NEW CONSTRUCTION SPACE -- SO
LOOK AT SOLAR PANELS -- HAVE A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR WARRANTY THE
ACTUAL LIFE CYCLE IS
CONSIDERABLY LONGER THAN THAT
THE MATERIALS INSIDE THE SOLAR
PANEL.
THE SILICON THE EVA THE BAKSHI
THE JUNCTION BOX THE GLASS THE
FRAMES ARE VERY DURABLE THERE
BEEN SOLD HILLS IN OPERATION FOR
IN EXCESS OF SIXTY YEARS -- THEY
DIMINISH DOWN ABOUT 80% OF THEIR
NAMEPLATE RATING AFTER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND THEN TEND TO STAY
AT ROUGHLY THAT OUTPUT.
SO THEY ACTUALLY WILL HAVE A
CONSIDERABLY LONGER LIFE -- THE
MATERIALS ARE ALL RECYCLABLE --
AND YOU KNOW I THINK ALONG WITH
THE EVERY OTHER MATERIAL AND
THAT'S ONLY GOING TO DEAL WITH
AT THAT TIME BUT I DON'T.
YEAH I DON'T SEE THAT THERE IS A
HUGE CHALLENGE.
I JUST THINK IT CAME FORWARD
BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING ISSUES WITH
RECYCLABLES AND THE WHOLE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY SO.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
INTERESTING -- THAT'S ACTUALLY
NEW INFORMATION CAUSES A LONGER
LIFE CYCLE YES A LOT MORE TIME
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO CONTEMPLATE
LET'S SAY A FEE RIGHT NOW.
IN TERMS OF DISPOSAL AND THINGS
THAT WERE ASKING OTHER ON
INDUSTRIES TO DO SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND AGAIN I WAS VERY
PLEASED WITHOUT OUR DISCUSSION
IN THE OFFICE.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
WANNA ALSO OFFER MY
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
REAPPOINTMENT AND NOW AS CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOUR FAMILY
FOR THEIR PRESENCE NOT ONLY
TODAY BUT FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF
YOU AND SHARING YOU WITH THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO WON A KNOWLEDGE YOUR
FATHER WHO I THINK IS A
CALIFORNIA TREASURE AS WELL AS
AN AUTHOR AND I LEADER ON ON
MANY FRONTS SO IT'S GREAT TO SEE
YOU HERE TODAY AS WELL -- I
ENJOYED OUR CONVERSATION IN AND
WANT TO BRING YOU BACK YOU
ALLUDED TO IN YOUR RESPONSE TO
SENATOR ROTH -- TO WIND ENERGY
IS PART OF OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY
PORTFOLIO.
IS YOU KNOW I REPRESENT AS PART
OF MY DISTRICT SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY AND AND NOW
DECOMMISSIONING.
DIABLO CANYON THE LAST NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT IN OPERATION IN
CALIFORNIA SET TO DECOMMISSION.
WE TALKED SOME ABOUT PROSPECTS
ALONG CALIFORNIA'S COAST FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF WIND ENERGY.
WHAT ARE THE OPPORTUNITIES THERE
WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES IN?
HOW IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
ARE THEY A PARTNER AS WE PURSUE
WIND ENERGY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION -- SO I AM PERSONALLY
REALLY EXCITED AND OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF OFFSHORE
WIND JUST TO PUT IT IN CONTEXT
WIND ON LAND IN CALIFORNIA
GENERATES ELECTRICITY.
ABOUT 35% OF THE HOURS OF THE
DAY OFFSHORE WIND IS APPROACHING
60%.
AND THE RESOURCES IS ENORMOUS
IT'S ALSO HIGHLY COMPLIMENTARY
IN THE GENERATION PROFILE TO
SOLAR SOFTER WHEN IT'S UP IN THE
MORNING.
DOWN THE MIDDLE THE DAY COMES UP
IN THE AFTERNOON EVENING.
AND THE SIZE OF THE TURBINES IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER SO ON LAND
IT'S TYPICALLY ABOUT TWO
MEGAWATTS OFF SURE THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO TWELVE MIKE
WANTS. TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE. FIFTEEN RPM SO IT'S
ONE ROTATION EVERY FOUR SECONDS
OF THE TURBINE TOWERS A HOUSE
FOR A DAY THAT'S THE SKILL THAT
WERE OUT TODAY.
ON WE'RE LUCKY TO BE A COASTAL
STATE AND IN PARTICULAR IN THE
CASE OF DIABLO TO HAVE SHORELINE
INTERCONNECTION.
I VISITED THE APPLE CANYON LAST
WEEK WITH MY COLLEAGUE
COMMISSIONER DOUGLAS THERE'S
ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT IS CURRENTLY PLANNED TO BE
DECOMMISSIONED AT A REPAIR COST
OF FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT IF YOU PUT OFF FOR WIND YOU
WOULDN'T NEED TO DECOMMISSION
OUT IN FACT IT'S SORT OF A TWO
FOR BECAUSE OF YOU DO OFFER WHEN
THERE.
YOU WOULD AVOID HAVING A BILL
THAT SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE STATE --
THE AND THE OTHER THING THE
TECHNOLOGY FOR CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DEEP WATER
SELF ALL THE TURBINES IN
CALIFORNIA UNLIKE THE EAST COAST
THE UNITED STATES.
ARE ALL WOULD BE ON FLOATING
DECKS -- YOU CAN PUT THOSE --
FIFTEEN MILES OUT WHERE THEY'RE
NOT VISIBLE FROM SHORE YOU CAN
PUT HIM CLOSER TO SHORE -- YOU
CAN BE FLEXIBLE THAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED AN OFFSHORE WIND
TASK FORCE AND ARE DIGGING INTO
THIS WITH ALL OF OUR PARTNERS
INCLUDING THE NAVY THE COAST
GUARD THE LAND COMMISSION
BECAUSE COMMISSION.
AND MANY OTHERS IF WE DO IT IN.
STATE WATERS WHICH IS UP TO
THREE MILES THAT'S SOME OF THE
LATER LIVED IN TERMS OF NOT
HAVING TO DEAL WITH THE THE
PROMOTION OR TO MANAGEMENT IF WE
DEAL IN FEDERAL WATERS.
IT IS LEASED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S A PROCESS
WERE WORKING THROUGH RIGHT NOW
THE OBJECTION THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES WITH THE NAVY.
I BELIEVE THERE'S A PATH FORWARD
THERE AND WE CAN FIND A COMMON
GROUND THAT MEETS THEIR CONCERNS
BUT CAN STILL -- ALLOW US TO
MOVE FORWARD AND AND OFFICER
WIND CAN BE AN IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR ENERGY MUSIC TO THE STATE.
WELL THANK YOU IN I'M GLAD THIS
IS SO PROMINENT IN NEAR.
RADAR IN -- WITH COMMISSIONER
DOUGLAS AND SHE'S BEEN VERY
ACTIVE IN THIS AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT.
AND THEN JUST MY FINAL QUESTION --
BACK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THERE'S BEEN SOME DEREGULATION
OF SOME OF OUR ADVANCES ON
APPLIANCE.
ISSUES AND SAFETY AND ALL THE
WAY UP -- TO QUESTIONS AS TO
WHETHER CLIMATE CHANGE IS REAL
OR NOT -- HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE
THE CURRENT WORKING RELATIONSHIP
PARTICULARLY ON ENERGY ISSUES
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
IT COULD BE BETTER -- I WILL SAY
THIS I MEAN WE'RE GOING TO
VIGOROUSLY DEFEND OUR PRODUCE
AND PUSH S HARD AS WE CAN
THERE'S THINGS LIKE APPLIANCE
STANDARDS. FOR THE PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE ENERGY STAR WHICH MAKE
NO SENSE TO ME -- HOWEVER I WILL
SAY THE WAY OUR SYSTEM IS SET UP
THE UNITED STATES TODAY MOST OF
THE POWER TO DRIVE A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE MOST OF THE
AUTHORITIES.
REST WITH THE STATES SO OUR
INTERCONNECTIONS STANDARDS ARE
P. S..
TAX CREDITS PERMITS -- AND MANY
OTHER THINGS ARE STILL STATE
DECISIONS AND SO ON YOU KNOW
WE'RE MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS
AND I POINT OUT YOU KNOW EVEN
UNDER -- PRESIDENT TRUMP STILL
THE MAJORITY OF NEW GENERATION
CAPACITY COMING ON OF THE GRID
HAS BEEN RENEWABLES -- STATES
ARE STILL DRIVING THAT AND THE
COSTS ARE LOW SO -- I'M STILL
VERY OPTIMISTIC WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE UP PROGRESS
[inaudible]
WELL.
I COULD GO ON BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND EVERYONE
GATHERED HERE TO OFFER THEIR
SUPPORT -- I WILL STOP THERE
MADAM CHAIR AND WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING -- YEAR
APPOINTMENT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
MINING -- AND THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME YESTERDAY TO HAVE MUCH OF
THE CONVERSATION WE'VE HEARD IN
PUBLIC TODAY.
CAN I ASK YOU JUST ONE ON ONE
THING WHICH IS.
TO EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON YOUR
STATEMENT ABOUT DISADVANTAGED IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
PRIORITIES AROUND --
ACCESSIBILITY FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY CAN YOU TALK JUST A
LITTLE BIT BRIEFLY ABOUT MORE OF
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW TO MAKE
THAT.
THIS IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR US IN
EVERY POGRAM WE OPERATE WE HAD
ACTUALLY BRIEFING ON AT OUR
COMMISSION MEETING THIS MORNING --
EVEN OUR DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
FOR R. D. 35% OF THOSE HAVE BEEN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES -- AND
WE DO A LOT OF OUR REACH YOU
KNOW THE NEW SOLAR HOMES PROGRAM
HOW TO CARVE OUT FOR FOR LOW
INCOME AND AND MANY PROGRAMS ARE
SET UP THAT WAY.
GIVE A TASK FORCE IT'S JUST
FOCUSED ON OUTREACH FOR OUR
PROGRAMS.
I WILL SAY IT WITH AN ISSUE LIKE
EFFICIENCY.
EFFICIENCY ITSELF WHEN WE ADOPT
NEW CODES AND STANDARDS AND AND
BUILD EFFICIENT BUILDINGS.
THE BENEFITS OF THAT A CREW.
ESPECIALLY TO DESERVE AS
COMMITTEES BECAUSE UTILITY BILLS
ARE A LARGER SHARE OF THEIR
ANNUAL INCOME AND YOU LOOK AT
FOR EXAMPLE AT THE FAULTS RAID.
A HOMEOWNER DEFAULTS VERY OFTEN --
AND BOBBY INMAN I'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS QUITE A BIT YOU KNOW.
THE HOMEOWNER CAN AFFORD TO PAY
THE MORTGAGE BUT NOT THE
MORTGAGE PLUS THE ENERGY BILL
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
STAYING HOME AND NOT SO WE TAKE
THE STUFF REALLY SERIOUSLY --
AND IT'S IT'S REALLY AT THE TOP
OF OUR MIND AS WE APPROACH ALL
THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA ASK MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE WHO ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT TO LINE UP AT THE
MICROPHONE.
AND GIVEN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
HERE AND THE NUMBER OF ITEMS WE
HAVE I WOULD ASK YOU. TO BE
INCREDIBLY BRIEF IN YOUR
COMMENTS BUT GIVE US YOUR NAME
WHO YOU REPRESENT.
AND YOUR POSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU WELCOME.
I'M BOB BREMER SENIOR ENGINEER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO GIVE A ME TOO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT IN US.
SOCIO ASIAN ARE THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
AND A SPECIFIC LAW -- ISSUE THAT
WE WORKED ON TOGETHER -- WAS THE
NEW SOLAR HOMES PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM -- WITHIN A THREE YEAR
PERIOD AS WE WERE COMING OUT OF
THE DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY WE
WENT FROM A SOLAR PENETRATION --
IN NEW HOMES FROM LESS THAN 1%
220% -- AND THAT HELPED US WORK
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION IN IN
GOING FORWARD WITH THE SOLAR
MANDATE THAT TOOK US ABOUT FIVE
YEARS TO REACH AGREEMENT ON WE
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KENT LEACOCK ON THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
AND PUBLIC POLICY FOR PRO TERRA.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT YOU
KNOW WE ARE ONE OF THE SUCCESS
STORIES THAT -- COMMISSIONER
HOSTILE ALLUDED TO WE WERE NOT
EXIST IN ABOUT THREE AND A HALF
YEARS AGO IT RELATES TO
CALIFORNIA.
NOW WE HAVE TWO MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES AND CREATED HUNDREDS.
OF JOBS AND WE'RE DRIVING
INNOVATION IN THE ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT BUS SECTOR AS WELL AS
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER SO I WANTED
TO SAY THAT WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT HIS APPOINTMENT AS CHAIR
OF THE COMMISSION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JASON OCCURRED WITH
THAT'LL STING GO OVER ROPES AND
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION.
JUST BRIEFLY WANT TO SAY WE WE
APPRECIATE COMMISSIONER HOAX
FIELDS COMMITMENT TO THE STATE'S
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HIM MORE ON THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION I'M
THERE LI MEI FROM THE CITY OF
FREMONT.
AND SO CERTAINLY VERY PLEASED TO
BE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
CHAIR HOOKS CHILD.
SAILED ON FOR HIS WORK WITH OUR
CITY AND THE PARTNERSHIP AS HE
MENTIONED -- TESLA IS IN THE
PROCESS OF EXPANDING AND THOSE
TYPES OF EFFORTS WE APPRECIATE
THE PARTNERSHIP AND A PARTICULAR
MOST RECENTLY AND SOME LIGHT OF
SOME OF THE NATURAL DISASTERS
THAT SO MANY CITIES AND FACING
TO BE PREPARED.
AND THESE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
NEEDS SO SUCH AS THAT PROJECT
THAT WE WERE LOOKING AT WITH
THREE OF OUR ELEVEN FIRE
STATIONS TO BE ABLE TO
MICROGRAMS.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US AND WITH
THEIR DISCUSSION I WAS LISTENING
TO YOUR QUESTIONS REGARDING.
MAKING SURE THAT HOW DO WE GET
ET ADOPTION THE FACT THAT WE'RE
BUILDING IS INFRASTRUCTURES AND
WE'RE ALSO DOING THAT NEXT LEVEL.
EVEY CHARGERS TESTING IN FREMONT
OTHERS ARE ALL OPERATIONS THAT
WE CAN PUT PARTNER AND THAT THAT
ENCOURAGES OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO ADOPT THE TECHNOLOGY
AND WE HAVE THE MOST EVEY
DRIVERS PER ANNE'S OF CODE IN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK THIS IS
WORKING FOR US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH XEROX
[inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME IS LAUREN OF
OUR OVERMAN VERY MENTAL DEFENSE
FIND HERE AND SUPPORT WE THINK
THAT -- KRISTER HAWK SHE'LL IS
ABSOLUTELY THE BEST PERSON FOR
THE JOB HE AS THAT COMMITMENT
ABILITY IN THE VISION TO GET
THIS DONE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS STAN GRESHAM A GOOD
ALTERNATIVE I ALSO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS A AS THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE CDC'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ADVISOR GROUP -- WERE REVISED
BUT THE P. PCNC SEE ON THEIR
PROGRAMS AND HOW THEY'RE
IMPACTING LOW INCOME
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES -- I
CAN SAY FROM.
MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE BOTH IN
THE COMMISSIONERS.
ARE FOR YOUR CURRENT ROLE BUT IN
HIS PREVIOUS LIVES AS WELL HE'S
A STRONG ADVOCATE. FOR A CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION THAT IS
INCLUSIVE OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ON LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
URBAN COASTAL RURAL.
CALIFORNIA SO WE SO I ASSUME IS
PART OF HIS REAPPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU.
I'M SURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MATTHEW SANDERS I'M AT THE
PACIFIC OCEAN ENERGY TRUST ALSO
KNOWN AS POET -- WERE A
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS
OFFSHORE NOBLE ENERGY ALONG THE
WEST COAST WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF COMMISSION HOPE SHIELDS.
EFFORTS AS AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
INDUSTRY AND WE LOOK FOR TO WORK
IN THE IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREW ANTS
WE WOULD SHOW YOUR HANDS WE HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY.
WHERE TRADE GROUP WITH MEMBER
COMPANIES ARE EITHER OFFER
PRODUCTS OR PURCHASE?
ENERGY AND THAT KIND OF A
UNIFYING MESSAGE WE HAVE A
NATIONAL PRESENCE A HEAVY
PRESENCE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE UNIFYING MESSAGE IS WE WANT
PRODUCTS AND POLICIES THAT
FOSTER SAFE AFFORDABLE AND CLEAN
ENERGY.
AS THE COMMISSION ALSO HAS A
TRACK RECORD SO THIS IS A VERY
EASY CHOICE AND WE COMMEND HIS
CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU.
I'M CHAIR MEMBERS ARE MORE THERE
HAPPENS TALK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS IN DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH CHAIR HAWK SHIELD
FOR OVER A DECADE AND A VARIETY
OF CAPACITIES.
I CAN ASURE YOU THERE IS NO ONE
WHO IS MORE DEDICATED TO A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA OR
FOR SHOWING THE CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE WAY IN THE STAB WISHING THAT
CLEAN ENERGY AND A GROWING
ECONOMY GO HAND IN HAND.
HE IS THE RIGHT LEADER AT THE
RIGHT TIME WE THANK YOU THANK
YOU PLEASE CONFIRM.
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF OF MC
MARIN CLEAN ENERGY THE STATE'S
FIRST CCA IN SUPPORT OF HIS
CONFIRMATION TODAY APPRECIATE
HIS LEADERSHIP BUT AS IT COMES.
BOB PROCUREMENT OF RENEWABLES
AND ESPECIALLY ENSURING THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN LOW
INCOME RIGHT PAIRS AREN'T LEFT
BEHIND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER
FOR PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY WERE
THE CCA IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
COMMISSIONER HOCHSCHILD
CONFIRMATION TODAY.
HE'S ALWAYS BEEN AN INNOVATIVE
AND THOUGHTFUL LEADER WHEN IT
HEARING THAT HERE TODAY AS HE
TALKS ABOUT HOW CLEAN ENERGY CAN
BILL CLIMATE RESILIENCE WHICH WE
CERTAINLY KNOW.
WE NOW NEED GOING FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO SHARON COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ALLEY TEACHER AND I'M WITH
ANGIE WERE GLOBAL CLEAN ENERGY
DEVELOPER IN CALIFORNIA WE FOCUS
ON EFFICIENCY SOLAR STORAGE IN
MICROGRAMS.
I'M WITH THE COMMISSIONER HOOK
SHOWS A GREAT LEADER AND
CHAMPION FOR INNOVATION
ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK TO DO
THINGS LIKE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
CONTINUING MICROGRAPHS.
AND IN A AND BLOCKCHAIN
TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
BLOCKCHAIN TECHNOLOGY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- MATT
FREEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF COMMISSIONER
HOPE SHIELDS CONFIRMATION -- I
HAD THE PLEASURE TO WORK WITH
COMMISSIONER HELP SHIELD FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS.
AND IT HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE HE IS A TIRELESS AND
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
LEADERSHIP HE LEADS WITH
ENTHUSIASM AS YOU CAN TELL --
ENCOURAGEMENT AND COMMITMENT TO
USING CALIFORNIA AS A MODEL FOR
OTHER STATES AND OTHER NATIONS
TO FOLLOW.
ON THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
HERE TODAY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF HIS CONFIRMATION INDICATES
THE FACT THAT HE WORKS WELL WITH
A VARIETY OF STAKE HOLDERS HE
TREATS EVERYBODY WITH INCREDIBLE
RESPECT.
PROMOTE CIVIL DIALOGUE.
NOT ONLY REACHES OUT TO STAKE
HOLDERS REALLY MAKES AN
INCREDIBLE EFFORT TO INCLUDE
EVERYBODY IN THE PROCESS AND
THAT'S FROM THE STAFF WORKING AT
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROCEEDINGS IN FRONT OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION -- GROUPS THAT
OPPOSE HIM AND GROUPS THAT
SUPPORT WHAT HE'S DOING.
HE'S DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB
OVERSEEING THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD PROGRAM AND
THE POWER SOURCE DISCLOSURE
PROGRAM AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
AND HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN VERY
MINDFUL OF THE IMPACT OF THESE
POLICIES ON AFFORDABILITY FOR
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS NOMINATION
AND HOPE YOU SUPPORT IT TODAY
THANK YOU.
I ALEX WORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EDDIE ON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
BRIGHT LINE DEFENSE HERE TO
VALIDATE -- COMMISSIONER HOPE
SHIELDS WORK ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES PARTICULARLY
BABY HUNTERS POINT AND OF COURSE
THE DOCTOR SPINOLA JACKSON THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU -- HELLO I'M LARS AGAR
I'M HERE AND HAVE THE HALF OF
THE CASTLE WIND -- WHERE AN
OFFSHORE INDDEVELOPER WHO HAS
A PROPOSAL -- OFF THE COAST OF
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
OBVIOUSLY MUCH OF THE DISCUSSION
TODAY WAS MUSIC TO MY EARS AND I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR MINING FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP BUT I'M GONNA
TELL A VERY BRIEF STORY VERY
BRIEF ABOUT -- THE CHAIR AND HIS.
ROLE IN OFFSHORE WINDS ABOUT MEN
HERE IS OUR FOUNDER ALL ALIGNED
SCENE CAME TO MEET WITH OTHER
CONCERN MANY YEARS AGO AT THIS
POINT.
AND SHE WAS VERY MUCH USED TO
DECISION MAKERS -- LAUGHING AT
THE IDEA THAT CALIFORNIA HAD A
FUTURE WITH OFFSHORE WIND -- MR
HOCHSCHILD ACTUAL DID NOT LAUGH
AND TOOK IT SERIOUSLY I THINK.
THAT DEMONSTRATES HIS LEADERSHIP
AND IS IN MERRY -- VISIONARY
MINDSET WHEN IT COMES TO HELPING
CALIFORNIA MEET IT'S CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE SO WE ARE VERY
ANTI IS A NEWS THE ETHICALLY AND
SUPPORT OF HIS RECONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARIAN
BERGESON WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS MY
COLLEAGUES -- WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MIXTURE OF HOPE
SHIELDS REESE -- REAP --
CONFIRMATION ON HE'S BEEN
SOMEONE WHO OBVIOUSLY FROM THIS
DISCUSSION TODAY SORT OF
UNDERSTAND A HUGE RANGE OF
ISSUES.
I ALSO KNOW THAT JUST IN THE
LAST MONTH OR TWO AS HE STOPPED
IN HIS CHAIR HE'S ACTUALLY MET
SO MANY OF HIS STAFF PEOPLE
DIRECTLY AT RT REACH OUT INTO
EVERY DEPARTMENT TO KIND OF
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT WHAT ARE THE
INNER WORKINGS OF THE
ORGANIZATION. TO HAVE SOMEONE
WHO CAN BOTH GET PERSONAL AND ON
THE DETAIL LEVEL OF SUCH A LARGE
AGENCY AS WELL AS I UNDERSTAND
THE OVER ARCHING ISSUES IS
REALLY UNIQUE AND SPECIAL.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
CANNOT SOLVE CLIMATE CHANGE
ALONE HE'S ALSO WELL POSITIONED --
TO BE ABLE TO CARRY THE
CALIFORNIA STORY OUTSIDE OF OUR
BORDERS OUR POLICIES ARE
TECHNOLOGIES HOW WE'RE MAKING
THIS WORK WHILE STILL HAVING A
ROBUST ECONOMY.
THIS NEEDS TO BE SHARED AND HE'S
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THE HUBBLE
HAVE CALIFORNIA'S IMPACT RIPPLED
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CATHERINE
BRANDENBURG WITH THE BRANDENBURG
WITH REPRESENTING CINEMA CLEAN
POWER -- ELECTED JUST.
VOICE OVER ON OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE COMMISSIONER AND ALSO LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE AGREE WITH ALL
THE COMMENTS AT THE OTHER --
FOLKS HAVE MENTION AND SPECIALLY
AMOUNT FRIEDMAN RETURNED AND HOW
YOUNG.
THE QUESTION OF WORKS WITH ALL
STAKE HOLDERS AND WANTS TO KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND HOPE YOU
COMPARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS FRED NOWHERE
REPRESENTING CARL GUARDINO IN
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
WITH VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF IT.
APPOINTEE TODAY JUST TO BE
INDULGE ME FOR THIRTY SECONDS --
MY FATHER WAS A MEMBER OF THE
COMMISSION.
IN THE IN THE IN THE NINETIES
HE'S NINETY THREE YEARS OLD NOW
AND HE STILL PRACTICING IT WAS
ONE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF HIS
CAREER SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEFF
YOU'RE AWESOME WITH THESE BIG
COMMUNITY ENERGY THIS IS A
BRIGHTER FOR ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS METERS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THAT THE
COMMISSIONER FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS NOW -- SINCE HE WAS AT THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE AND EVEN BACK
THEN HE WAS ABLE TO IDENTIFY
SOLUTIONS TO THE CHALLENGES WE
FACE TODAY.
AND REALLY HELPED USHER IN THE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY FROM VERY SMALL NICHE
INDUSTRY THAT IT WAS AROUND THE
TURN OF WHINY HIM. TO THE
JUGGERNAUT THAT IS TO DIE TODAY
NOW DELIVERING CLEANEST LOWEST
COST RENEWABLE ENERGY ON ACROSS
ANY TECHNOLOGY AND GRADE.
AND HIS ABILITY TO SEE THOSE
SOLUTIONS AND THEN NOT ONLY --
CAMPAIGN TO SEE THEM DELIVER BUT
THEN EXECUTE ON ACTUALLY
DELIVERING THEM AS BEEN VERY
TRANSFORMATIVE AND THAT'S
EXACTLY THE KIND OF LEADERSHIP
WE NEED TODAY AT THE COMMISSION
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SERRA RAFELSON AND I'M FROM EVEY
GO EVEN GOES THE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF FAST CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WERE BASED
AND WEST LA WITH OFFICES IN
OAKLAND AS WELL.
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT TODAY AND
ALREADY BE GO HAS ABOUT HALF OF
THE PUBLIC FAST CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
RESIDENTS LIVING IN MULTI UNIT
DWELLINGS -- AND AND THOSE
WITHOUT ACCESS TO CHARGING AT
HOME AND IN THE WORKPLACE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
SCALE OUR TRANSPORTATION OCT
VACATION -- THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP -- THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE CHAN I REPRESENT
THE GREEN LINING INSTITUTE AND
ALSO SERVE ON THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ADVISORY BOARD.
AND FOR ALL OF THE REASONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SPOKEN ABOUT HERE
TODAY WE WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF OF THE CHAIRS CONFIRMATION.
AND I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT THE CHAIR IS A CHAMPION OF
SO MANY GREAT EXCITING.
ANSI SEXY TECHNOLOGIES BUT IS
ALSO A REALLY GREAT CHAMPION FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY WHICH OFTEN
TIMES CAN GET OVERLOOKED BECAUSE
IT'S NOT AS EXCITING AS A
MICROGRAM OR A SOLAR PANEL.
BUT NOT ONLY AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BEFORE DOES THAT
REALLY HELP FOLKS WITH -- WITH
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD THEIR
ENERGY BILLS BUT ALSO MAKES
HOMES MORE HEALTHY MORE
COMFORTABLE AND SAFE -- FOR FOR
FOR RESIDENTS AND THAT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHANNON EDDIE I REPRESENT THE
LARGE SCALE SOLAR SUSPICION
ABOUT A TEN YEAR OLD -- RIP
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
UTILITY SCALE SOLAR -- HAVE
WORKED WITH A CHAIR FOR FOR MANY
MANY YEARS AGO EVERYTHING THAT
HAS BEEN SAID.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TO LEAVE YOU ALL WITH HIS
AFFECTED THAT THE CHAIRS A
PRAGMATIC VISIONARY.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED
TO TAKE CALIFORNIA FROM WHERE WE
ARE NOW TO A ZERO CARBON FUTURE
NOT JUST BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
BUT EVEN FASTER SO -- URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JEANINE COTTER IN
IRAN -- WOMAN RUNS SOLAR COMPANY
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND WE HAVE A
VERY STRONG -- FOOTPRINT AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
GETTING KILLING PEOPLE UP AND
GETTING THEM ENGAGED IN.
WORKFORCE HI AND AND BECOMING
SOLAR INSTALLERS AND WORKING
WITH CLEAN ENERGY.
DAVID WAS THERE AT THE VERY
COMMISSION HOAX KILLED WITH
THEIR AT THE VERY BEGINNING AND
HE BUILT A COALITION AND SAN
FRANCISCO TO CREATE GO SOLAR AS
STAFF.
A IN COLLABORATION WITH THEN
MAYOR NEWSOM IT WAS.
REALLY THOUGHTFUL REALLY
PRAGMATIC AND TRANSFORMATIONAL
FOR THE LIVES OF MANY PEOPLE WHO
CAME IN THROUGH RE ENTRY LONG
BEFORE WE KNEW.
THE WORD REENTRY
TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAD MULTIPLE BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT -- AND I STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND CAN TELL
YOU THAT.
THERE ARE FOLKS THAT BEFORE WERE
ON ASSISTANCE AND NOW OWN THEIR
THEIR LIVES -- AND HAVE MANAGED
TO BATTLE ADDICTION BY GETTING A
PAYCHECK EVERY WEEK.
HE IS ONE OF THE MOST THOUGHTFUL
[inaudible]
INNOVATIVE PRACTICAL PEOPLE THAT
REALLY INCORPORATES NOT JUST TO
THE ENERGY BUT ALSO HOW ENERGY
IMPACTS THE LIVES OF PEOPLE.
AND HE REALLY INVESTS IN
COMMUNITY AND UNDERSTANDS IT.
I'M AND I JUST LIKE TO MENTION
MOTHER ESPIN ALLAH JACKSON --
WHO SIX YEARS AGO WAS HERE WITH
US AND IS NO LONGER HERE -- AND
I MISS HER PRESENCE AND HER
LEADERSHIP -- AND HER KICK IN
THE ****. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO RIGHT -- BUT I KNOW THAT SHE
SPEAKS TO DAVID.
A COMMISSIONER WHO STILL THE
EVERY DAY -- AND THAT SHE WILL
KEEP IT RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND PLEASE
DO RECONFIRM HIM BECAUSE HE WILL
DO GREAT THINGS FOR CALIFORNIA
AND FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR TO MANY HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF ENERGY SOURCE THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION.
THE SEGMENT MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
DISTRICT THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS EDEA FOR NOBLES EDP
RENEWABLES FOR SOLAR.
AND THE SOLAR ENERGY INDUSTRIES
ASSOCIATION THIS IS NOT A CREW
THAT USUALLY AGREES ON MUCH.
BUT WE AGREE THAT MR HOCHSCHILD
IS THE BEST THING FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE THING FOR
CALIFORNIA AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S ADRIAN
UNDERWOOD AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING SON RUN THE
NATION'S LEADING RESIDENTIAL
SOLAR AND STORAGE -- SERVICES
COMPANY -- AND THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER -- HEADSHIELD HAS.
OUR DEMONSTRATORS THAT STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO CLEAN ENERGY AND
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE CALIFORNIA --
IS APPLIED AS VISION SUPPORTING
THE EFFORTS OF REMOTE RENEWABLE
ENERGY CLEAN TECH INNOVATION AND
BUILDING A COLLABORATIVE
ENVIRONMENT WITHIN THE
COMMISSION AND THE COMMUNITY AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE JUST TALK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LILLIAN MARVIS I'M A GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR OWN CAN ACT --
CONNECT AS A RESIDENTIAL DEMAND
RESPONSE SOFTWARE PLATFORM THAT
PAYS PEOPLE TO SAVE ENERGY.
WE HAVE MET WITH COMMISSIONER
HOOKSHOT ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT INNOVATION
LOOKS LIKE IN TODAY'S VIEW OF
THE GRADE OF THE FUTURE AND
COMMISSIONER HOPE SHE'LL
CONTINUE TO BE SUPPORTIVE AS WE
CAN COUNTER BEARS WITH.
DIFFERENT I'LL USE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN REALLY
PUSH FORWARD TOWARDS -- A
COLLABORATIVE DISRUPTIVE FUTURE
SO FOR THESE REASONS -- CONNECTS
THE PORTS THAT COMMISSIONER HOPE
SHIELD CONFIRMATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PRO TEM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
DANIELLE AS BORN MALES HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION.
INSTRUCTS SUPPORTIVE
COMMISSIONER WHO KILLED THREE
APPOINTMENT EVERY CONFIRMATION
AS CHAIR -- HE IS EXPERIENCED
ENTHUSIASTIC AND ENGAGED AND
EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO KIND OF
STUDY THE MARKET IN CALIFORNIA
AND LEAD US INTO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CLEAN ENERGY
LEADERSHIP SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN WHITE
WITH THE CENTER FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY RENEWABLE
TECHNOLOGIES A LOT HAS ALREADY
BEEN SAID I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF
BUT JUST WANT TO SAY HOW TO'S
ASK WE ARE ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH MISTER
HOPE SHE'LL.
HIS ENTHUSIASM IS EVIDENT BUT
HIS LEADERSHIP STYLE IS
INCLUSIVE AND ITS DEMOCRATIC AND
HE HAS ALREADY LISTED MORALITY
COMMISSION PEOPLE GENERALLY
EXCITED ABOUT BEING THERE AND
PARTLY BECAUSE OF HIS COMMITMENT
TO THEM AS PEOPLE -- HE SPENDS A
LOT OF TIME WITH STAFF IS NOT
JUST ONLY MEETING THE THE THE
IMPORTANT PEOPLE HE'S HE'S HE'S
HE'S BUILDING A TEAM AND AND I
THINK HE'S GOING TO HELP THE
GOVERNOR.
OF LEAD US IN SOME CONSTRUCTIVE
NEW DIRECTIONS TOWARDS GETTING
ALL THIS DONE THAT WE'VE
PROMISED THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE PHILLIPS WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA DITTO TO
EVERYTHING THAT HAS BEEN SAID SO
FAR A WEEK AND THESE YES ECKLEY
URGE YOUR I VOTE ON THIS A GREAT
CANDIDATE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I MOVE THE CONFIRMATION MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
SENATORS BASE.
MINING BATES.
BATES I SORRY MORNING.
MORNING I ROSS.
ROSS I WILL.
WILL COME I ASK HIM TO SIGNA
CONCISE SO YOU'VE IN THROUGH CAS
STICKLEY BEEN UNANIMOUSLY
CONFIRMED.
REGULATIONS.
AND WE'RE GONNA IT TAKE A FEW
MINUTE BREAK BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT AND I HAVE MY COMMITTEE
HERE OR WE'RE GONNA.
LIVE THE CALL ON ITEMS TWO
THROUGH EIGHT BUT RECOGNIZING
THAT -- SENATOR BATES WANTED TO
MAKE A COMMENT ON ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE HI YES THANK YOU I'D JUST
I'D MAKE A POINT ABOUT THE
GRANTING OF RULE WAIVER SOB.
SO A DEAL CAN BE HEARD TOMORROW
IN SENATE JUDICIARY UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENS -- AND THIRTY NINE
LET ME ASK -- EVERYONE -- TO
TAKE YOUR COMMENTS OUTSIDE I
KNOW.
IT'S A GREAT MOMENT BUT I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO HEAR SENATOR BATES
THANK YOU.
I CAN HARDLY HEAR MYSELF.
I AGAIN THANK THANK YOU FOR I
JUST A MOMENT OPPORTUNITY --
REGARDING -- THE GRANTING OF
REAL WAIVERS I SAW BILL CAN BE
HEARD IN NAM SENATE JUDICIARY
TOMORROW I AM AWARE OF WHAT
HAPPENED ON A LITTLE MISTAKE WAS
MADE AND CERTAINLY ON THE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT EVERY MEMBER
SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
HAVE THEIR BILLS HEARD IN A
POLICY COMMITTEE SO I'M GOING TO
BE VERY SUPPORTIVE BUT I JUST
WANT TO PUT ON THE PUBLIC RECORD
I BELIEVE IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
POINT TO BE MADE THAT.
ALL SENATORS ARE AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THEIR
BILLS IN COMMITTEE -- THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE ALL UP HERE IN THIS
INSTITUTION TO DO SO THAT YOU
KNOW.
IT CAN BE SUPPORTED CAN BE
OPPOSED OR SOMEONE NEEDS SOME
MORE TIME ON IT BUT IT SHOULD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD.
A LOT OF WORK GOES INTO THOSE
BILLS FROM STAFF ON BOTH SIDES
AND THE AUTHOR HIMSELF AND THOSE
WHO SUPPORTED IN THOSE WHO
OPPOSE.
SO JUST WANTED TO HAVE THAT ON
THE RECORD MADAM PROTIUM.
THANK YOU AND ON ON NUMBER FIVE
I WOULD JUST SAY -- YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S NOT OFTEN YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE A WAIVER AT RULES
COMMITTEE BUT GIVEN THE NATURE
OF MY HOUSE OF ORIGIN DEADLINE
THE NUMBER OF COMMITTEES.
THAT THIS PARTICULAR BILL WAS
REFERRED TO WAS TRIPLE REFERRED
I BELIEVE.
I'M WE ARE HUMAN AS CHAIRS AND
VICE CHAIRS AND SIMPLE MISTAKES
HAPPEN AND STAFF WORKED VERY
HARD TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CORRECT.
A MISTAKE OF OF OF A IN TERMS OF
PROCESS AND THIS ENABLES THIS
BILL TO CONTINUE TO BE HEARD SO
THANK YOU.
SENATOR BATES -- WE WORK
OVERTIME TO MAKE SURE WE FOLLOW
THE RULES.
AREN'T WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE.
THIS THE DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN LEADERS SUPPORTING A
WAY TO RESOLVE.
THE ISSUE AND WE THANK YOU FOR
THAT [inaudible]
SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU ON THIS POINT MADAM
CHAIR NOT TO BELABOR IT BUT I
APPRECIATE.
SENATOR BATES COMMENTS AND I
KNOW.
OUR CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE HAD
A FAMILY HEALTH ISSUE YESTERDAY
AND I JUST WANT.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE VICE
CHAIRS BEEN DOING AN AMAZING JOB
IN IN HE STEPPED UP IN.
FILLED IN YESTERDAY AS AS
REQUIRED AND IT WAS --
UNFORTUNATE OVERSIGHT -- AND
THAT'S ALL IT WAS SO I DO
APPRECIATE -- SENATOR BATES
RECOGNITION OF THAT AND I DO
WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
GRADATION OF THE VICE CHAIR --
REPRESENTING THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY ON THE COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IS A VERY BUSY DAY.
OUT WITH THAT -- MADAM SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BASS.
BATES I ROUGH ROUGH BY THAT'S
FINE AND THAT IS FIVE ZERO AND
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THANK YOU --
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE JUST A FEW
MINUTES I WANNA MAKE SURE -- OUR
FOLKS HAVE A CHANCE TO REST
THEIR FINGERS AND TAKE A BREAK
AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK IN FIVE
MINUTES THANK YOU
.
OKAY I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE MEETING BACK TO ORDER.
AND INVITE MICHAEL TONIGHT WHO
WILL BE A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION TO
JOIN US.
LET ME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE -- FOR THE LAST.
HOUR AND A HALF AND WELCOME YOU.
I INVITE YOU TO INTRODUCE ANYONE
YOU WOULD LIKE TO THIS WITH YOU
AND MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS
AND THEN WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS WELCOME --
MY WIFE IS A GENE A SMALL
REMODEL IT LET'S SEE IF LET LET
ME SEE IF THAT MIKE IS ON AND
JUST SO WE CAN HE GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BETTER.
I'LL TRY NOT SHOUT.
UP ANYWAY SHE MY WIFE JEAN
COULDN'T ATTEND BECAUSE WE GOT A
HOUSE FULL OF COUNTRY.
CONSTRUCTION PEOPLE MOVING IN
AND OUT OF OUR HOUSE.
SHE'S THEY'RE MANAGING THAT.
I WOULD LIKE.
TO OPEN MY STATEMENT WITH JUST A
LITTLE BACKGROUND.
ON MY CAREER.
IF I MAY UP BECAUSE I THINK IT
WILL HELP YOU ALL -- UNDERSTAND
THE WAY IN WHICH I'M GONNA
ANSWER QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
FOR ME.
I HAD.
THE FORTUNE OF GROWING UP IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY AND MY FAMILY DID A LOT
OF CAMPING AND FISHING THEN.
I'M ALWAYS HAD INTEREST IN BEING
IN THE FOREST.
AND WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE
ACCEPTED INTO CAL'S FORESTRY
PROGRAM BACK IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY
FIVE AND I HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE
OF HAVING.
DR HAROLD BUILDS WELL
[inaudible]
AS MY ADVISER AT THE TIME AND
AFTER MY FRESHMAN YEAR AT
ACTUALLY IT WAS SECOND QUARTER.
AND I I REALIZE JEEZ I'VE BEEN
AND I'VE GOT A WHOLE NOTHER YEAR
AHEAD OF ME OF PRETTY MUCH OF
PRE MED [inaudible]
TRAINING.
AND I HAD THE SPRING BURNED OUT
BLUES AND I WENT IN AND TALKED
TO HERALD.
HE SAID YOU KNOW.
I HAVE A GRAD STUDENT WORKING UP
IN YOSEMITE DOING HIS PHD WORK.
IN PRESCRIBED BURNING AND HE
NEEDS IN THE SYSTEM.
IF YOU WOULD.
BE WILLING TO TAKE YOUR SPRING
QUARTER.
UP AND WORK WITH HIM I WILL.
GIVE YOU A YOU KNOW WHAT I
FORGET WHAT THEY CALLED IT AT
THE TIME IT WAS [inaudible]
I COULD.
GET CREDIT BUT NOT A FULL
QUARTERS WERE THE CREDIT AND I
WENT UP THERE AND WORKED WITH
THIS FELLA YON VAN WEIGHTON DONG.
WHO EVENTUALLY BECAME THE
RESEARCH BIOLOGIST FREE SEVENTY
PARK?
AND WE SPENT DAYS OUT PUTTING
THEM PLOTS AND THEN TORCHING
THEM.
AND I LEARNED THE SCIENTIFIC
PROCESS FROM HIM BUT THAT
CEMENTED MY CAREER AS A FORESTER.
AND I WAS HOOKED [inaudible]
AND THEN.
I MOVED TO SANTA CRUZ AND SO
HUNG OUT A BIG CREEK UNTIL THEY
GOT TIRED OF STEPPING OVER ME
AND THEY EVENTUALLY HIRED ME BUT
YET.
IN THAT SHORT PERIOD OF TIME I
WAS AT CAL FIRE FIRE FIGHTER.
AND AND THEN WENT ON AFTER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND AND WENT
TO WORK FOR MEDICINE -- REDWOOD
COMPANY SO I'VE HAD A BACKGROUND
OF WORKING WITH SMALL NON
INDUSTRIAL LANDOWNERS IN THE
SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS.
AND THEN WORKING FOR A BIG
COMPANY.
WITH.
PRIVATE LAND HOLDINGS AND
SAWMILLS.
AND I IT IT REALLY DOES SHAPE
THE WAY I THINK ABOUT THINGS.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO SAY I AM VERY VERY
GRATEFUL TO BE APPOINTED.
BY THE GOVERNOR AND THE PASS
GOVERNOR -- I AM.
QUITE CERTAIN THAT.
WE HAVE VERY MANY CHALLENGES
AHEAD OF US AND A AS A BOARD.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU ALL THAT I
WILL WORK DILIGENTLY. TO GET THE
WORK DONE THAT IS BEFORE US.
SENATOR MINING LET ME START WITH
YOU THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
IN A WELCOME CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU YOU HAD ME WITH UC
BERKELEY.
GO BEARS -- BUT WE'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF KNOWING EACH OTHER.
THROUGH RECENT YEARS -- MICHAEL
IS A CONSTITUENT WHEN HE'S HOME
IN SANTA CRUZ IN A SURFER.
BUT I'VE KNOWN YOU IN YOUR
PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY IS A FOR
STERN A MANAGEMENT OF LARGE
FORESTRY IN HELPING. TO BE A
LEADER IN -- I WOULD SAY CULTURE
CHANGE IN FOREST MANAGEMENT OF
LEARNING IN LEADING A PROCESS
THAT'S POST GOOD.
FOR THE FORESTRY INDUSTRY AND
GOOD FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
ECOLOGY AND I THINK YOU AN
APOLOGY FOR THAT LEADERSHIP.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS POSITION --
YOU REFERENCED BIG CHALLENGES AS
GOVERNOR BROWN SAID WE'RE LIVING
IN A NEW ABNORMAL WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE IN.
FIRE SEASONS BEING EXTENDED.
QWERTY WITH WITH THE THE BREADTH
OF THESE CHALLENGES.
WHERE WHERE OUR ENERGIES BEST
DIRECTED I KNOW THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE FIX BUT WE HAVE THE
INTERFACE BETWEEN?
POPULATED AREAS SOME WILD FIRE
AREAS WE HAVE LARGE FORCE MANY
OF WHICH ARE US FORESTRY.
MANAGED OM WHERE DO WE FIND THAT
BALANCE AS YOU MOVE FORWARD --
WHERE DO YOU WANT TO SEE THE
STATE PUT ITS ATTENTION?
IT IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO DO
A MULTI PRONGED ATTACK AT THIS
WE WON'T GET THE WORK DONE THAT
WE NEED TO DO OTHERWISE
[inaudible]
FIRST WE HAVE TO ENGAGE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THEY
CONTROL A LOT OF FOREST LAND.
IN THE STATE.
THE SECOND IS WE HAVE TO INVEST
IN INFRASTRUCTURE IN TWO FORMS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE INDUSTRY THAT
WE ONCE HAD HERE IN CALIFORNIA
OF TRAINED WORKERS TO GO OUT AND
DO THE KIND OF WORK.
THAT AT LEAST PART OF THE
EQUATION IS ACTUALLY GETTING ON
THE LANDSCAPE.
AND DOING THINGS MUSICALLY WITH
THE FOREST.
SO GETTING PROGRAMS RESTARTED I
THINK WORKING WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO BRING PEOPLE INTO
OUR INDUSTRY.
IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL I THINK
CAL FIRE IS MADE SOME INCREDIBLY
GREAT STEPS RECENTLY.
OF GETTING PEOPLE INTO TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
BROAD VARIETY OF TRAINING.
THAT WILL HELP THAT ALONG.
THEN THE OTHER HARD INVESTMENT
IN EQUIPMENT THAT IS NECESSARY
TO DO THE WORK -- AND ALSO AGAIN
CHARLIE.
BUILDING BACK INFRASTRUCTURE
HARD IN THE STRUCTURE MILLS.
COGENERATION PLANTS THAT SHOULD
FOLD INTO THE RENEWABLE WINDOW --
IS THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE.
SOME.
GUARANTEES AT LEAST.
POLICY GUARANTEES THAT THE
MATERIAL THAT WILL RUN THOSE
FACTORIES AND HIRE THOSE PEOPLE.
IS GOING TO BE THEIR LONG TERM
AND NOT JUST A SHORT SPLASH IN
THE PAN.
SO THERE'S THAT ONCE WE GET THAT
ESTABLISH I THINK [inaudible]
THEN.
THE THE WORK.
ON THE LANDSCAPE.
WILL ACCELERATES SLOWLY IT'LL BE
SUBSIDIZED EARLY ON BY THE STATE
BUT I THINK PRIVATE CAPITAL WILL
COME INTO PLAY.
THANK YOU AND THEN.
AND JUST A FINAL QUESTION FOR ME
I KNOW THAT THE BOARD STAFF HAS
OVERSIGHT OF WORKING WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN REVIEWING.
LOCAL PLANS -- FOR WILD FIRE
SAFETY AND PROTECTION BUT NO
AUTHORITY FOR IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT OR MAY BE FINE
TUNING THOSE PLANS HOW.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT STATE OF
PLAY IN?
DO YOU HAVE THE AUTHORITY
NECESSARY.
TO ACHIEVE MAXIMUM ANA LOCAL.
INVOLVEMENT.
WE HAVE WE HAVE THE OVERSIGHT.
OF THE LOCAL PLANS.
WE CAN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT THEY DON'T ALWAYS HAVE.
TO TAKE THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE MAY.
I WOULD BE HESITANT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. TO USE THE STICK.
VERSUS THE CARROT.
AND SO I THINK AGAIN WITH SOME
[inaudible]
EDUCATION.
I'M AND WITH THE INCREDIBLE
STAFF THAT WE HAVE AT THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY.
THAT INTERFACES WITH COUNTIES IN
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS --
INCENTIVIZING.
THINGS THAT THEY SHOULD SUPPORT.
AND PUT INTO CODE IS THE BEST
METHOD RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I THINK AS WE DISCUSSED.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE EVERY.
SELF INTEREST AT THIS POINT IN
TRYING TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY SO.
SOUNDS LIKE IT IS A PARTNERSHIP --
MOVING FORWARD.
ON I THINK THAT'S GOOD.
MADAM CHAIR JUST APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS.
TO ADD THIS TO YOUR CONTINUED
PORTFOLIO OF WORK IN OUR FORESTS
AND FIRE SAFETY I HAVE THE TIME
TO DO IT NOW.
AND I'M REALLY HAPPY TO BE.
ABLE TO DO IT AND HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF MY MY EMPLOYERS.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU AND GOD AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS A REAPPOINTMENT
AS REALLY ARE.
THEY YOU KNOW THAT'S A
CONFIRMATION THAT WHAT'S GONE
BEFORE WE WANT TO RETAIN IT
BECAUSE IT WAS VERY HIGH QUALITY
SO.
ODD THAT CERTAINLY YOUR RESUME I
HAVE.
I BELIEVE YOU ALL HAVE DONE A
GOOD JOB AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEVEL -- UP TO THIS POINT AND I
KNOW THERE'S A STATEWIDE
VEGETATION TREATMENT PROGRAM
THAT'S IN THE WORKS IN MY
COMMUNITY OF ALL SOUTH ORANGE
OUNTY YOU PROBABLY REMEMBER
SOME OF THE PRETTY.
HORRIFIC FIRES THAT OCCURRED
THERE -- MID TWO THOUSAND SOLD
MY MY INDIVIDUAL -- HOME.
A COMMUNITY LAGUNA MIGUEL WE
HAVE A FUEL -- MANAGEMENT PLAN
IS SO WE WE HAVE TO HAVE A FUEL
MODIFICATION AS PART OF ANY
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THAT WAS THE COUNTY -- WHEN
WE WERE PRE INCORPORATION AND
THEN IT CAME FORWARD WITH OUR
INCORPORATION SO IS WORKED VERY
WELL OUR HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS
ARE HAVE TO BUY INTO THAT WITH
THE C. C. AN ARSENAL LONG SO?
IT'S A GREAT MODELING YOU
PROBABLY.
KNOW ABOUT IT HI CERTAINLY WITH
THE PASSION THAT YOU HAVE THAT
GOES BACK TO CHILDHOOD YOU ARE
YOU ARE FORCED MAN SO.
ARE YOU CERTAINLY ARE GOING TO
HAVE MY SUPPORT BUT YOU MIGHT
WANT TO JUST SHARE IN IT WHEN
THE VEGETATION TREATMENT PLAN IS
IN THE WORKS AND WHEN IT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT.
CAN IN IN REALLY RIGHT I'D LIKE
TO SAY YOU ENJOY THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE IN THERE AND
VERY WELL RECEIVED BY.
OUR RESIDENTS.
I DON'T HAVE A FIRM TIMELINE
WINDS THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE.
OUT AND USABLE.
I'M IT.
IT'S GONE THROUGH.
A LOT OF CHANGES OVER THE YEARS
IT'S BEEN CHALLENGED IN COURT
AND I THINK THEY'RE WELL AWARE
OF THE COMMENTS THAT CAME IN THE
LAST TIME.
WE AND THIS WAS BEFORE I WAS ON
THE BOARD.
YOU KNOW TRIED TO GET IT IN
PLACE BUT ONCE IN PLACE I THINK
IT WILL BE THE ROAD MAP FOR ALL
OF THE VARIOUS COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT THE OTHER GOOD THING IS
THAT WE UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE
LEARNED.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
ABOUT THE SEVERITY.
OF FIRES THAT INNER COMMUNITIES
THAT.
WHAT WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T AND
CERTAINLY THOSE ITEMS WILL BE
INCORPORATED INTO THAT AS WELL
AND SHARE?
IT WITH THANK YOU I JUST ONE NOW
SOME FINAL COMMENT WITHOUT DOUBT
PRESENT IN SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
IF YOU REMEMBER THE LAGUNA FIRE.
MANY YEARS AGO IT WOULD HAVE
JUMPED A LEASE -- CANYON WHICH
IS HE RUNS DOWN TO THE BEACH IN
LAGUNA BEACH AND BECAUSE WE HAD
FUEL MODIFICATION GOING ON AT
THAT TIME IT DID NOT LEAVE THAT
CREEK.
IF IT HAD IT COULD REALLY ARE
TAKEN OUT A HUGE PORTION OF THE
COASTAL AREA OF LAGUNA BEACH
LAGUNA GAL DATA POINT.
RIGHT ACROSS THE HIGHWAY THERE
SO I'M CERTAINLY A STRONG
SUPPORTER AND I HAVE IT ON MY
BACKYARD.
AND ON SUNDAYS I WISH I COULD
PUT A LITTLE MORE SOMETHING OUT
THERE AND THEN I THINK -- NO.
FINE TO HAVE JUST THE THE KIND
OF SCRIPT DOES ALLOW THEIR THEN
SOMETHING THAT IS COMBUSTIBLE
BECAUSE THAT WOULD SWEEP UP.
CERTAINLY VERY QUICKLY AND I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE EMBRACED
THAT SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
AND YOU CERTAINLY HAVE MY
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRE IS CERTAINLY A MAJOR PART
OF THAT ECOSYSTEM DOWN THERE
YEAH HAVING PEOPLE RECOGNIZE
THAT NOW I THINK IT'S BEEN A
GOOD THING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR VICE CHAIRMAN.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF.
THIS LET ME SAY -- VERY
IMPRESSIVE CREDENTIALS AND
BACKGROUND -- WE'RE LUCKY TO
HAVE YOU.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING
YOUR CONFIRMATION.
GRADUATIONS PLEASE GO FORWARD
AND NOAH I CONCUR WITH YOUR
COMMENTS SENATOR ROTH ON GO
FORWARD WITH YOUR MOTION -- DARN.
OKAY ALL OF YOU FOLKS WHO HAVE
BEEN WAITING SO PATIENTLY I
DON'T KNOW WHAT I AM THINKING.
OUT WE WANT TO HEAR MORE GOOD
COMMENTS ABOUT MR JINNAI AND NOT
TO PREDETERMINE ANYONE WHO MIGHT
BE HERE IN OPPOSITION -- BUT
PLEASE.
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR COMMENTS
YOUR SINGLE PICKY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE AND HONOR TO WORK
WITH MIKE AND I BOTH OF THE
BOARD MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE FORCE FOUNDATION AND WE
APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU.
GERRY WRITERS AND GREEN DIAMOND
RESEARCH COMPANY -- MY CAN I GO
BACK A LONG WAYS -- MIKE'S JUST
BEFORE IS ONE OF THE THREE
INDUSTRY MEMBERS ON THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY STIPULATED BY.
BY STATUTE -- MIKE'S ABILITY TO
AND AND SENATOR YOU'VE YOU
CALLED THE RIGHT HIS ABILITY TO
RECOGNIZE THE RENAISSANCE THAT
NEEDED TO OCCUR IN THE IN THE IN
THE MID NINETIES AND TO BE ABLE
TO REACH ACROSS CONSTITUENCIES.
AND REACH OUT TO THOSE
CONSTITUENCIES CONSTITUENCIES
AND LOOK AT FOREST HOLISTICALLY
AND NOT JUST FROM FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF OF TREES.
AS YOU KNOW IT MAKES THE LEADER
IN THAT SO I'D I'D CREATURE YOUR
APPROVAL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANDREA HELLO SIERRA PACIFIC
INDUSTRIES AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
MAKES APPOINTMENT TO THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY HIS BREADTH OF
SUPPORTING THE INDUSTRY WORKING
ON BEHALF OF THE INDUSTRY OVER
THE YEARS.
BRINGS A VALUED VOICE TO THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY AS THEY ARE
TACKLING THESE. FOR A CALIFORNIA
FOREST HEALTH ISSUES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME THANK YOU A JOHN
ANDERSON WITH HUMBLE TEN MINUTES
YOU KNOW REDWOOD COMPANIES.
MIKE HAS BEEN MY MENTOR SINCE I
WAS A STUDENT AND I I I AM WHAT
I AM TODAY BECAUSE A LOT OF WHAT
HE'S DONE AND USED ON THAT FOR A
LOT OF FORESTERS AND I'VE JUST
SEEN HIM IN ACTION OVER THE
YEARS AND JUST AMAZED WHEN WE
PURCHASED -- HUMBLED REDWOOD
COMPANY AND HAD TREE SITTERS UP
IN TREES.
HE WENT OUT THERE AND TALKED HIM
DOWN WORDS NO ONE ELSE COULD
HAVE EVEN THE POLICE CAN GET TO
HIM BUT MIKE TALKED ABOUT.
SO IS THAT KIND OF PERSON THAT I
CAN WORK WITH THAT YOU KNOW IT
JUST ABOUT ANYBODY AND CERTAINLY
YOU'VE HEARD HIS EXPERIENCE AS
BACKGROUND YOU'LL BE A GREAT
ASSET TO THE BOARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIRMAN.
GOOD TO SEE AGAIN I'M LIKE BRAD
SHAW WITH THE HEARST CORPORATION.
AND I THINK I'VE KNOWN MIKE
LONGER THAN ANYBODY IN THE
ENTIRE ROOM WE WERE IN.
A SUMMER CAMP AT BERKELEY IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AND THAT
WAS A LONG TIME AGO -- I TOTALLY
SUPPORT -- YOUR APPROVAL OF MIKE
TO THIS POSITION HE COULDN'T BE
A BETTER SPOKESMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE INDUSTRY.
AND I KNOWN HIS WIFE JEANNIE FOR
ABOUT FORTY THREE YEARS AND
STILL KEEP THEM IN LINE.
SO.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE -- HERE ACTUALLY IN A
PERSONAL CAPACITY IS URGING YOUR
CONFIRMATION OF MISTER JULY
BECAUSE I HAVE HAD THE WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY OF FIRST -- HAVING
HIM AS A CLIENT OF MINE AND THEN
AS A FRIEND AND ALL I CAN SAY IS --
THE STATE PARTICULARLY THE THE
BOARD BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE VERY
THANKFUL FOR HAVING HIS
EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE IN THIS
NEW CAPACITY.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
NOW YOU'RE MAKING A MOTION --
MAN SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS BATES.
BATES I MINING.
MINING I ROSS.
ROSS I WILL I WILL GUY AT CAN.
INSIDE ITS UNANIMOUS.
AND MR TONIGHT THANK YOU I
GUARANTEE YOU THEY DON'T ALWAYS
GO SO EASY SO -- SO WE WE
COMMEND YOU AND THANK YOU --
THANK YOU
.
WELL THANK YOU ALL I WE WILL ON
A JOURNEY INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION